dans la famille shinobi devant le petit
modèle dont le petit frère je demande le
chien au mil mi aux elle ait mis onze
light 5g parce qu'il existe deux
versions du million slide cette année
une version 4g une version 5 g vous
l'aurez compris l'idée c'est vraiment de
différencier les gammes pour proposer
pour toutes les bourses dans quelques
temps les modèles seront tous 5 j'ai
donc la question se posera plus haut
niveau de la dénomination entre le
maillot de la 4g le mur life 5g on l'a
vu d'ailleurs chez samsung n'ya pas
longtemps je sais pas si vous vous en
souvenez au niveau du samsung galaxy à
52 ya une version 4g via une version 5 g
c'est sensiblement la même chose ici
avec semis aux light si les différences
de versions d'ie également différence de
prix la version 4g étape 329 euros
contre 399 90 et 6 me semble-t-il
quasiment 400 euros donc là qu'est ce
que nous propose ce midnight a quasiment
400 euros et bien pour moi il a trois
points majeurs trois points vraiment
intéressant qui font que vous allez
pouvoir venir acheter et je vais tout
vous il ya tout de suite
[Musique]
c'est toujours d'une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec rhinochill
parce que oui avoir un beau smartphone
c'est bien mais il faut penser à venir
le protéger bruno chiche a proposé de
plus en plus de coqs pour les modèles de
chez home il y en a plein c'est sympa
donc si vous avez déjà un smartphone de
chez eux au miti dans cette liste là eh
bien je vais pouvoir avoir une coque et
les protections de rhinau gillet gaccio
pourquoi pas si vous envisagez de venir
changer votre smartphone ça peut être
l'occasion d'avoir un smartphone avec en
plus une coque de rhinau chine qui est
très sympa donc ça c'est bien une fois
de plus je mets le lien en bas dans la
description chéri vous propose des
protections d'écran pour semer 11 light
et vous avez notamment plat de
protection développe là il y en a plein
chez rhino chine avec notamment les
impacts screen protector qui alors ce ne
sont pas les modèles pour le million
d'iphone voyez ça écrit si noir sur
blanc mais néanmoins où vous avez des
modèles pour cette référence et ça c'est
très bien et en plus de ça si vous êtes
fan de manga il ya une toute nouvelle
collection qui sort ses nike heroes
acadamy à les modèles sont sympa très
chouette je vous les montre en avant
première et puis bien évidemment je suis
arrivé chez vous savez vous avez une
grande gamme au scrutin petit tour
complet vous avez notamment de la solide
suite carbone ou tout noir comme ça très
sympa à plein du fort knight à droite à
gauche c'est sympa vous avez également
des coques approuvé par la nasa vous
avez dû interrupteur fairy tail
assassination classroom des comme dans
le sport avec notamment là une vieille
et si les chicago bulls et bien
évidemment vous avez la crh garnet du
mode enix vous et pouvoir soit garder le
dos apparent ou alors met une backplate
à l'arrière en appelant dans différents
univers notamment league of legends
c'est très sympa donc vous avez 5 % de
remise avec mon code il est juste en bas
ici cliquez sur le lien présent dans la
description vous allez économiser
l'argent devait venir protéger votre
smartphone dans les meilleures
conditions où ça c'est vachement bien
regardez-moi ça comme c'est tout
millions ce petit million 7 alors le
mieux aux grecs il est assez sympa la
très grande force qu'il a avec vous
présente tout de suite et bien c'est son
design son design et son format regardez
ça la finale du truc c'est vraiment
complètement dingos c'est un truc que
j'ai tout de suite vraiment aimé et
adoré lorsque je les débats lorsque je
les prie aime alors je n'avais vu lors
de la présentation mais je n'avais pas
pris hier mans et c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui change énormément
regardez-moi ça il est très très très
très faim il extrêmement compact et
surtout ici au niveau du module photo
vous
ici à 1,77 mm d'épaisseur ne serait-ce
qu'au niveau du module photo donc ça
c'est vachement intéressant parce que
avec les smartphones vous avez vraiment
une miniaturisation qui va se faire au
niveau de la partie photo au niveau des
appareils photo et le fait d'avoir
quelque chose de très fins comme ça eh
bien écoutez moi je trouve ça assez
bluffant est vraiment pas mal alors on
va regarder la configuration photo dans
quelques instants nous on va regarder si
le résultat est à la hauteur mais en
attendant est-ce qu'on voit ici et ce
qu'ils jouent aussi c'est la finesse du
produit il est extrêmement fin on est à
6 80 mm d'épaisseur et surtout le point
il est vraiment très très très léger
c'est un smartphone qui fait 159 g
c'est tout fin tous les gestes un format
que j'aime beaucoup donc ça j'apprécie
beaucoup j'apprécie également le fait
que vous élisent deux matelas qui prend
pas trop les traces de doigts vous avez
en plus son truc et très sympa ici c'est
le capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
est positionné sur la tranche pour sa 7
boutons de volume et en fait on trouve
très facilement sa position on peut à
peine et il est verrouillé y a pas
besoin d'appuyer et quand vous rhabiller
dessus vous utilisez le bouton pour
l'appuyer vous l'éteignez donc vous
posez votre doigt vous n'appuyez pas
pour le déverrouiller il se déverrouille
automatiquement donc ça c'est vraiment
vraiment génial donc en termes
d'expérience de prise en main de
positionnement des boutons de format là
dessus j'ai omis afin super boulot et
pour moi c'est le tout premier point
extrêmement positif qui fait que vous
devrez venir vous positionner sur ce
smartphone à un tout petit peu moins de
400 euros
le 2e puck est super intéressant c'est
son écran ici vous avez un écran signée
samsung
on est sur une dalle amoled l'écran est
un peu mastoc 6,55 pouces c'est ce qui
se fait aujourd'hui on est dans l'air du
temps dans l'idée du contenu du vice
zonage du multimédia et du gaming et
bagarres des vous avez un très grand
écran full hd + un grand classique 2400
par 1080 ça marche très très bien aussi
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement de
90 ans à un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile en 240 m bon voilà là dessus y'a
rien de bien surprenant ça fonctionne
bien il est bien calibré il assez
lumineux il marche bien donc pour toute
l'expérience du multimédia pour me
regarder des films des séries pour bien
vous faire plaisir
là vous avez aussi un super bon
smartphone très très bel écran signée
samsung intégré dans ce smartphone de
chiens oui et ça c'est très bien donc ça
c'est le deuxième point positif
et puis le troisième point positif eh
bien c'est la performance vous avez ici
un processeur qui marche super bien pour
tes soeurs signé qualcomm
c'est le site un dragon 780 g g pour
gaming vous connaissez un peu l'histoire
on va voir 8 gigas de ram c'est la lp
dédié à 4x mais c'est une fois de plus
qu'on vient à temps dans ce segment de
prix on à 128 giga de stockage en fs 2.2
c'est ce qu'on attendrait dans ce
segment de prix là ça fonctionne mais
surtout ce snapdragon 780g il est
vraiment bien très réactif et en terme
d'expérience pour venir jouer c'est
génial et vous montre un petit exemple
sur un jeu on va se faire un petit parti
de mortal kombat j'adorais jeu lorsque
j'étais plus jeune donc là c'est
vraiment il est vrai qu'on n'est pas sur
le jeu dungeon qui tourne pas une fusée
mais malgré tout ça répond ça marche pas
nous pouvons faire tourner plein de jeux
du pays histoire donc autant
d'expériences de gaming s'arrache bien
alors maintenant il ya tout ce que je
veux un petit peu moins aimé dans ce
smartphone et qui ne paraissent pas
dingo dingo déjà c'est l'expérience
audio l'expérience audio je dois
reconnaître que je suis au mit aurait pu
faire beaucoup mieux
en fait ce qu'a voulu me refaire shiomi
là dessus c'est dire ok on va se mettre
des haut parleurs stéréo parce que les
haut parleurs stéréo c'est super tout le
monde vit des hauts parleurs stéréo on
en parle donc on se met des haut
parleurs style sauf qu'ils sont rentrés
dans le travers des haut-parleurs stéréo
mais à un petit peu moins de 400 euros
je ne tiendrai pas rigueur
c'est à dire vous mettre un haut parleur
qui est ici et qui part de ce côté là et
l'autre qui est le haut parleur vous
utilisez pour passer des coups de fil ça
c'est un très grand standard et on
retrouve aujourd'hui sur quasiment tous
les smartphones donc ça ne pose pas de
problème et je le comprends
sauf que ici on vas pas pouvoir me dire
vous avez une superbe expérience
thériault c'est pas vrai il arrive dans
cette
dans cette configuration là d'avoir
effectivement un décalage ici moins de
graves - de basse et un son un peu moins
fort bien évidemment mais là il ya quand
même un certain déséquilibre le son sang
sont au delà il est trés médium on va
manquer de gras fatalement le son des
haut-parleurs de smartphones on a manqué
de précision d'ailleurs bonjour anne
qui ici en photo c'est un bon pote donc
il sait voyez c'est pas où on se dit
effectivement j'ai des hauts parleurs
stéréo c'est super bien d'arrêter
l'expérience là dessus et pas dingue
et en plus de ça dans ce segment de prix
très souvent on retrouve une prise jack
et ici chez tommy a fait le choix de ne
pas vous mettre deux prises jack à un
peu moins de 400 euros
néanmoins et le point positif parce
qu'il faut quand même des points de
positif sur la partie audio ou bien vous
êtes du bluetooth 5.2 avec plein de
codec apt-x et compagnie donc vous avez
de quoi faire donc ça ça ira
autre point qui est un petit peu en
dessous c'est la partie de l'autonomie
vous avez intérieur une batterie de 4250
milliampères heures on va pas tenir deux
jours on va tenir une journée
si vous êtes un peu plus cool vous
tiendrez un poids de plus pour venir
aller jusqu'à une journée me met pas
plus pas au delà
point positif parce que les points
positifs bien évidemment vous avez un
blog de charge rapide de 33 watts qui
vous permet de le recharger quand même
assez rapidement alors user il vous faut
à peu près une heure pour me relancer de
0 à 100% vous le savez je voulais déjà
dit on ne décharge pas sur smartphone
jusqu'à 0 % pour le rush 1 jusqu'à 100%
non on laisse son smartphone arriver aux
alentours de 20% et on le remonte
jusqu'à 80% comme ça on vient éviter la
dégradation plus rapide des cellules on
emmène sa batterie plus loin dans le
temps un point qui est sympa c'est toute
l'expérience logiciel avec me why me
wade douce basée sur l'android 11
je vous ai déjà parlé 2012 change xiaomi
l'année dernière il ya eu quelques
petites mises à jour faite entre temps
ça marche bien aller voir ma vidéo sur
me wade 12 vous allez voir que me wade
12 c'est très sympa et vous vous en
douterez parce que ça des usages très
fort c'est toute la partie photo la
partie photo on s'en doutera à un petit
peu moins de 400 euros
eh bien ça va faire des merveilles doit
pas avoir une machine qui va être dingue
dingue au comme ce qu'on va voir sur le
million sous alors sur le mieux aux
ultras dont on parle d'ici quelques
jours d'ailleurs vous invite à venir
vous abonnez vous cliquez sur le petit
bouton rouge qui est là si les rouches
et vous n'êtes pas abonné vous actionnez
la cloche comme ça vous serez notifié
dès qu une prochaine vidéo arrivera et
ça c'est une très bonne nouvelle alors
regardez qu'est ce qu'on a ici à
l'arrière au niveau de la photo on voit
se décrypte un peu de s'apprécier tout
comprendre alors ici c'est notre capteur
principal c'est un 64 mégapixels on va
ouvrir et si af 1.79 en dessous on va
retrouver ici une caméra de macro sea
une 5 mégapixels touvre f 2.4 et au
dessus ici car des atouts petit cachet
ici eh bien vous avez un ultra grand
angle
c'est un capteur de 8 mégapixels touvre
f 2.2
avec un champ de vision 219 degrés donc
en fait ce qui nous intéresse lavandier
c'est qu'on n'a pas de caméra telle
objectif mais une fois de plus dans ce
segment de prix c'est normal ça ne
surprendra pas de pouvoir faire de la
vidéo jean 4k usagers à 30 images par
seconde c'est pas vraiment le smartphone
qui va être hyper bon en vidéo donc on
va pas parler de vidéo ici c'est
vraiment un usage en plus ce qui va nous
intéresser surtout c'est la partie photo
et vous avez sur le devant vous l'avez
vu une petite caméra de self inouïe de
20 mégapixels tout brève 2.24 s'il vous
plaît plaît on commence sur le capteur
principal lac albert à 64 mégapixels
on voit quand même plutôt pas mal dans
l'ensemble les nuages on voit sur notre
photo 1
mais je trouve que les couleurs sont
plutôt bien eu on le voit aussi au
niveau des petites feuilles des hommes
ça fonctionne dans l'ensemble c'est
plutôt pas mal
on passe sur l'ultra grand temps que
c'est tout de suite plus ternir on le
voit directement la regarder la
différence
là on a l'impression que la nuit vient
de tomber alors que ça se passe
exactement au même moment par contre on
voit un petit peu mieux les nuages
est ce qu'il ya un problème de gestion
des hautes lumières au niveau de ce
capteur principal 64 mégapixels on le
verra sur notre photo c'est beaucoup
moins agréable il vous faudra bien
évidemment ici beaucoup de lumière pour
profiter vraiment des conditions
optimales sur ce capteur ultra
grand-angle on continue ici avec un zoom
x 2 bien évidemment en fois de
n'utiliser la caméra de 64 mégapixels
dans laquelle on vient se nourrit donc
ça marche pas très bien on peut aller
plus loin jusqu'en faut 10 une fois de
plus on oublie on l'a déjà vu sur place
smartphone c'est la même chose ici on
peut aller en x 2 au delà on oublie
caméra principale ça semble fonctionner
c'est pas mal sur lui très grand-angle
on le voit bien évidemment ça à venir ce
jeune ir davantage
on va perdre à pau précision on voit
comme un musicien le ciel donc c'est
quand même plutôt pas trop trop mal dans
l'ensemble on peut zoomer un peu plus ou
dix ans x 2 ça marche bien il est
absolument aucun problème et des combats
au delà c'est pas terrible
la caméra de celle ci fait sensiblement
le taf sillage 12 ans mannequin vergne
at on est devant le stade marcel
michelin où se passent les matchs de
l'asm la caméra tlfi pas mal on perd un
peu en piqué mais rien n'est bien
surprenant ici sur une caméra de celle
fils est relativement classique vous
avez quelques photos en macro jeu pas
très très fade mais bon on peut faire
des petites choses si on souhaite en
macro est ce que lui
l'événement est ce que c'est réellement
intéressant je suis pas sûr malgré tout
c'est pas trop mal j'ai déjà vu bien
pire donc dans l'idée c'est pas mal ici
vous n'avez aucune stabilisation dont
des combos d'un petit peu c'est un peu
complexe nager c'est de bouger pour
essayer d'avoir cette fourmi s'était pas
dingue dingue dingue haut mais pour
avoir un bout de tissu sont bougés en se
calant sur le sol et en maintenant on
arrive à faire des choses assez rigolote
les photos ne lui sont pas dingue
franchement elles sont pas
extraordinaires une fois de plus on est
sur un smartphone à un tout petit peu
moins de 400 euros donc ça me paraît
normal
on va faire des photos de nuit on ira
ici sur le million 11 et les photos sur
l'ultra grand-angle bon je vous montre
histoire de montrer mais en capte pub
lumière c'est galère on les surnomme
très longtemps que c'est normal c'est
comme ça dans mon là dessus rien de bien
des colons donc voyez le smartphone il
ya trois points forts il a le design il
à l'écran est il à la performance il a
quelques petits points en plus qui sont
assez sympa notamment le fait d'avoir du
nfc pour le témoin dématérialisée avec
google paie le fait d'abord une double
sim ou une anodine plus carte microsd si
vous voulez augmenter le stockage
pourquoi pas on a du wifi 6 très bien
mais par contre ici vous n'avez pas de
certification ip pabx ip 67 paradis p 68
on absolument aucune certification je
pense qu'ici j'ai envie a voulu aller à
l'économie je ne doute pas que ce
smartphone soit étanche je pense que
s'il rencontre un peu de pluie ça
fonctionnera bien il y aura pas de
problème on évite de se baigner avec
deux parce qu'on s'est pas fait pour
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ici il n'ya
pas de certification
alors on a un smartphone qui est un tout
petit peu moins de 400 euros à 400 euros
dans ce segment de prix ya beaucoup de
monde ce qui est sûr et ce qui est
intéressant voyez c'est que chez au mit
à cette stratégie de venir inonder le
marché ils le font clairement vous avez
beaucoup de références d'ailleurs non
pas dans quelques jours avec une vidéo
qui nous récapitulons un petit peu la
gamme de chez oh oui même si c'est
compliqué de faire une photo en un
instant t parce que ça continue tout le
temps il toujours nouveau modèle qui
arrive ce qui est sûr c'est que celui là
le chien au mileu muse light il est
super intéressant et surtout plus plus
plus gros coup de coeur pour moi sur le
design sur la légèreté sur le format sur
l'épaisseur gelé ouvert ça m'a bluffé et
des je le prends dans la main
comparé à dodge adore je trouve que
vraiment un super boulot a été fait là
dessus par xiaoming au delà de l'écran
oled la performance qui sont aussi assez
extraordinaire dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
comment vous le trouver je suis au mi
2011 life moi j'aime beaucoup et une
fois de plus il faut aller dessus si
vous voulez un smartphone fin si vous
voulez un smartphone léger
et si vous voulez un smartphone qui ne
fera aucun compromis au niveau de
l'écran et au niveau de la performance
dites nous ce que vous en pensez en
barque commentaire quant à nous on se
retrouve très vite des bisous de l'amour
pour les fans du chaos